welcome to the fight of the Living Dead
experience to start at the beginning
click here or click the link in the
description below
team one location first Lord Bingham
tree area please you have a gun they're
not dying
where do we go this is follow me
this is look I don't trust you to leave
all three zombies aggression level high
them hence muscular abilities than hens
speed
all right
stay here don't move guys our laptop
idol will just be on it but I'm look hey
is all you overworked if you're seeing
this video we need your help the Army
has been rounding us up and putting us
in jail
quarantine especially were infected with
something but they won't tell us with
what they're keeping us locked up in
here like we're going to die a team of
us are getting together to try to figure
out what's going on myself dr.
Altagracia who's supposed to be some
kind of a genius
we've gotta do something food and water
in the tastic
what is the coat that I smear that out
what does this look this says footlocker
code that's what does that even mean
oh okay bring here 14:18 2189 Oh what
are those letters okay okay so you
working okay
and 18 is oh oh we get some condoms as a
Cheeto okay Justin left second floor
sweet
in this hall of the war which I use in
the boiler room
do you really want get out of boiler
rooms like if this is like you we should
leave right but that would be the
smartest thing to do in this situations
get out of here not go further deeper
into what we don't know what I we said
we need to hate to do okay all right
let's go to boiler room so let's try and
figure out what direction we are right
now so does to see any signs
I would just say grab a couple things
put them in your whatever
no you all right you okay
you are you effective you relax
no no hey no no no you go we're friendly
you affected you've been bit
oh who are you who are you good you get
the guns
you guy hunts what's your name Lex don't
blog it the weapon Tina with a boiler
rumors yes you do
okay we need to get that that's our only
way to safety free now okay listen pull
yourself together
it's just it's just office job ready
Jean solo and no nothing no no don't
listen to him
really not chill where do we go what do
you guys what is our zombie yes James
why do you need to go you go to boiler
boiler room unless we shoot somewhere
else that doors locked
oh don't go that way what yeah
no he's gonna go in there
you can do to the pipeline yes yes yes
we've two flashlights
good what was that
you know gross stop like a crazy dude so
oh my god I have something on an IV to
rip off right here and rip okay they're
soft they die easily okay we go into the
boiler room that's the only way to get
the formula the boiler room is right
past where I was taking them we've
turned back yes sir
say that again keeping missile
well I'm Justine and we're in the mess
hall right now I have no idea what we're
doing by no Joey
um don't know how I got mixed into this
mess finders jesse wellens hi youtube
channel prime first prank and if i die
my youtube password is avocado 98 so you
guys can have that I'm dead okay
which we can tell them I have no I have
no idea hi guys I don't want to say it
we gonna bail out of here
where's pepper how long he died
you got immediately a zip you in a bag
the days of you know right do you want
is what you guys what any food or
anything there's like sorry no yes it is
we're stuck in a place it's screwed
creepy as hell there's a bajillion
zombies everywhere cheese's I got a gun
I'm happy the crew still here we're
stuck in this room right now that's a
bit
yep you're on everybody else all right
so no I'm private James solo I'm here to
help
No